El Congreso de Perú rechazó nuevamente
el adelanto de elecciones durante el
debate tanto los congresistas de
izquierda como los de derecha expusieron
argumentos que ponían tropiezos al
avance de la Reforma algunos
legisladores se oponían a que las
elecciones se realicen en octubre de
este año mientras que otros rechazaban
que se recorte el mandato del parlamento
por su parte los legisladores de
izquierda jamás renunciaron a su
iniciativa de incluir una convocatoria
asamblea Constituyente algunos analistas
sostienen que tal como están las cosas
es muy difícil que este congreso apruebe
cualquier proyecto de adelanto electoral
porque señalan que no existe la voluntad
ni tampoco el deseo de sacar adelante la
reforma
Francisco aras Está debatiendo también
un proyecto sustitutorio Qué
posibilidades tiene de ser aprobado y
que incluye exactamente
Sí precisamente el congresista Jaime
quito que pertenece al partido
izquierdista Perú libre ha presentado en
minoría un texto alternativo que propone
que las elecciones se realicen dentro de
120 días esta nueva iniciativa tabí
incluye una consulta a los peruanos a
través de un referéndum de que si
estarían de acuerdos con que se convoque
a una asamblea Constituyente el
congresista quito ha solicitado al
congreso un receso para redactar el
texto tratar de conseguir acuerdos que
junten 87 votos entre los parlamentarios
el presidente del Congreso ha autorizado
esta solicitud y ha programado para
mañana a partir de las diez de la mañana
la reanudación del debate pero Fuentes
del Congreso señalan que si en la
anterior votación la izquierda le puso
tropiezos al proyecto de la derecha
ahora a la derecha le ha dado de volver
a la izquierda la misma jugada